in dieser friedlichen stadt in diesem
ruhigen straßen wird etwas schreckliches
etwas grauenhaftes
casillas ramos wird der sound ist
vordergründig erstmal ein zombiefilm das
gemacht hat ist erst mal so den wirklich
zu reduzieren auf die grundkomponenten
was man sagt wir haben untote und
schrotflinten stumpfe und scharfe waffen
und aber das war es auch erstmal was wir
nicht haben ist unendlich viele blätter
wir haben kein blut aus den zombies
regnet vornehmlich 18
wir haben auch nicht dieses tempo und
wir haben doch etwas mehr humor als man
das sonst bei diesen sommer protesten
irgendwie zu sehen bekommen denn die
kippen ja dann eigentlich doch immer er
ins ins ins garstige und wie gesagt es
ist ein sehr sehr entspannt dafür die
reden auch alle sehr entspannt jungs
sollten wir uns nicht gegenseitig sagen
dass alles wieder gut wird das alles
bald vorbei ist wie ein böser traum aber
eigentlich ist es so schön lakonisch die
ganze zeit und das schafft er eine ganze
zeit lang es wird dann manchmal sehr
sehr albern oder aber auch mitunter fast
tragikomisch manchmal gibt es auch und
dann bricht die sind dann wird es auch
wirklich dann wird es auch fast traurig
möchte man sagen und so lange er immer
platz lässt mir so ein bisschen zu
überlegen was uns da eigentlich gerade
zeigen will klar wir haben wie
klimawandel damit drin wir haben
irgendwie es wird aber immer deutlicher
dass es so eine konsumkritik
kapitalismuskritik abzielt die am ende
so überdeutlich wird ja in dem quasi
szenen gegen geschnitten werden mit
menschen die bestimmte beziehung zu
ihrem fetischen pflegen autos oder
was weiß ich was hat sie ihrer der
chardonnay gesagt und dann hat er uns
eigentlich aus diesen deutungen gedrängt
denn dann ist alles besetzt durch durch
die botschaft von jim jarmusch und wie
die welt geht kaputt aufgrund von
materialismus und eben unsere unsere
menschlichen gier quasi zumindest hat
man das gefühl also der cast besteht aus
punkt vielen wunderbaren populären
bonbons wir haben auf der anderen seite
die heimische musiker kumpel tom waits
und sogar bis es mit dabei von modellen
plänen und auf der anderen seite ein
sehr populäres ensemble bestehend aus
bill berry tilda swinton und r m 3 war
bei einem dreier würde ich sagen der
spielt irgendwie man hat sich an dem sie
schon ein bisschen satt gesehen das
spiel zu einer jüngeren version von
jüngere und langer regio version von von
von bill berry eigentlich mary wiederum
spielt mit diesen fantastischen
hundeblick einen etwas polizisten
eigentlich schon von anfang an gerne
feierabend machen würde müsste das schon
dunkel sein um die zeit
die umstellung auf sommerzeit die bringt
irgendwie alles was ungleichgewicht also
wer spaß an solchen hat kann sicherlich
auch in diesem film viel entdecken aber
da geht es eher so an referenzen er
keinen spaß an zahlen geschrieben hat
kann auch in diesem film gehen weil es
nicht so ganz so drastisch ist und die
blutigen szenen immer auch irgendwie
dadurch so ein bisschen kontrolliert
werden dass man sieht dass die leute
ebenso ein hühner viel leben und haben
wenn sie da irgendwie ihre leute
ausweiten und dann können wiederum die
leute die mit giuliano schwimmen nichts
anfangen können können da auch reingehen
weil es eben über die chance einen
anknüpfungspunkt gibt es das ganze ganz
interessant macht und die leute die mit
jim jarmusch etwas anfangen können die
können ja sowieso eingehen ich tippe auf
zombies
weisst schon und man hat bei jim
jarmusch immer eigentlich das gefühl
dass er sagt ja die welt ist manchmal
trist und lea und ungerecht aber seine
die handelnden personen setzten dem er
immer wieder so einen schon fast
absurden optimismus entgegen oder
transzendieren das immer so ein bisschen
und sagen du kannst immer noch was gutes
draus machen indem du weiß ich ein
gedicht schreibst ice cream oder aber
dich verliebst oder derlei dinge und
dieses mal ist zum ersten mal so das ist
kein optimistischer film mehr sondern es
wird auch immer gesagt leute das wird
nicht gut enden und aus der nummer
kommen sie dann auch nicht mehr aus
[Musik]